hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday June 11th 2018 what's going on
how are you I'm a [ __ ] old man
50-year old I remember when podcasting
started back in 2005 I just want to
throw that out there because I know
there's gonna be a bunch of [ __ ] old
podcast people going oh [ __ ] of the
podcasting has been round in Japan since
1958 and I started my podcast like four
years before years and I don't
understand what mine doesn't get as many
many hitches yu-er stood on who gives a
[ __ ] calm I actually look at the numbers
every week and I feel that we put catch
Julie come on chanted I'm I'm providing
computer would you shut the [ __ ] up I
love people look at that [ __ ] podcast
numbers you notice everybody seems to be
in the top ten everybody you know it's
like I've talked about this before it's
like it's like back when I used to do
college gigs every college I went to
somehow they figured out a way to fudge
the numbers that they were number one in
something you know the number one
[ __ ] school for mathematics the
number one school for engineering
doesn't that have mathematics in it I
don't know right and then we just so you
get down to a community college and
they'd be the number one commuter
college you know with [ __ ] the best
deal with triple-a or some [ __ ] I don't
know some other where number one or
something you got to hang your hat on
something if you're a college to try and
get people to go there if I if I was a
Dean do they have Dean's at like
community colleges I would just I would
go on [ __ ] TV and say listen why the
[ __ ] would you go four years when you
can only pay two years you know you want
to go to Harvard fine
all you have to go is your junior and
senior year go your freshman and
sophomore year over us over us we are
number one and being [ __ ] ten times
less per year than Harvard
you got the grades you know you're in
come on down
teach us dummies my dumb students I
don't we're [ __ ] locals with those
sucks whatever the [ __ ] it is you smart
people do do your freshmen and sophomore
year here translate translate [ __ ]
transfer over to Harvard and there you
go
and you can graduate from Harvard what a
dad DJ Giada whatever their [ __ ]
school song is what is this school so my
dad is rich and I did real bad in school
but he has money so I plug in here now
let's say that's a stereotype that's not
sure I knew I knew I knew one kid in my
high school he got into Harvard and he
did it with [ __ ] grades and no social
life
he made the sacrifices the rest of us
didn't want to do it you know like that
little fable there with the [ __ ] ants
saving all the food and the other
animals like amen I'm just jumping
around having a good [ __ ] time you
know you know who wrote that story I bet
somebody who couldn't [ __ ] it was
really socially awkward at a party so he
was looking at the [ __ ] what is it a
rabbit told us in the hair that's not
the story I don't know what it is but it
didn't you know people who aren't
outgoing they they get [ __ ] annoyed
by people who are outgoing who are out
there having a good time talking some
[ __ ] hooking up right singing songs be
in the life of the party they stand on
the side and the [ __ ] wall and they
write scripts you know so that's why now
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened back
in the day used to have cool people
movies now every cool person has this
underlying insecurity that they're
trying to overcompensate for that's
alright or [ __ ] I think you know I mean
some people just are the life of the
party
so anyways now that I'm a senior citizen
I banged out fifty-four push-ups on my
birthday boy and then immediately just
[ __ ] collapsed onto the
and was like out of breath like I ran
fifty four flights of stairs but I did
it man I did it I don't know what it
means it still means I'm 50 but it made
me feel pretty good about myself I had a
great birthday I want to thank my lovely
wife she surprised me with tickets to
the French Open Roland Garros Bonjour to
the moon we [ __ ] we went there and I
got to see what the [ __ ] is his name
that he's only one month
he just won his 11th Rafael Nadel that's
right I'm not the biggest [ __ ] tennis
guy and I knew that he had won this
thing a couple times I didn't realize
he'd already won the [ __ ] French Open
he'd already won it ten times and I saw
him win his 11th and what's really
interesting is that guy he won in Oh 500
607 Oh 8 and then Federer won a no 9
then he won in in 10 11 12 13 and 14 so
he went at four years in a row missed a
year and then went in five years in a
row and then two years 15 and 16 he
didn't win it so people probably all
thought all right his run is over he's
one of the Great's of all time but now
that he's old there bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla and he [ __ ]
comes back last year and this year to go
back to back again winning 11 and I was
talking to somebody last night we were
trying to say how what do you compare
that to in a different sport you know
you can't really say it's like winning
an NBA championship because there's only
one of those where with tennis majors
there's there's four so it's like they
have four sort of Super Bowls so we kind
of said I guess you'd have to go to golf
compare it to golfers where you know
there's four majors in that sport I
don't [ __ ] know I was kind of saying
well maybe it's like LeBron going to the
NBA Finals eight nine years and
it's like well no because this guy
actually won the thing I can't believe
people give him a brunch [ __ ] after
losing to that they people forget so
quickly you know how ridiculous it was
that Kevin Durant went to the Warriors
and then the very you know and then he
wins a championship people like what the
[ __ ] and they just kind of go this is
just how it is this is just how it is
like when they first put little [ __ ]
TVs in the back of cabs and people like
get these things the [ __ ] out of there
they're making me carsick then I go and
then later on they just put it back in
again and nobody said oh yeah I guess
this is just how I guess this is just
how it is right all right I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was going with that good
tennis golf majors [ __ ] but I mean just
the fact that this guy 111 or wrong and
I basically got to see on my birthday
the greatest I guess you'd have to say
the greatest player ever on clay I got
to see him I got to see the [ __ ]
Wayne Gretzky the Bobby all a tennis and
he was playing this other kid he broke
him his first game of both sets and the
kid had a bunch of unforced errors and
uh you know we could see he kept that
that the guy who lost it seemed like he
was a kid and he just had to go there
experience it lose make a bunch of
unforced errors for the next time when
he comes back and in the end right his
English dude comes out who won the
French Open I don't know it in the way
he was talking I was like late 50s early
60s and he came out to say bunch of
great [ __ ] about Raphael and they Dowell
and then when he talked about the other
kid he was just like going you know we
would have liked to see more we're
allowed to say more tennis and I'm sure
he's a little disappointed in his game
today as were the rest of us and
everybody just sit there Connelly dude
he didn't need to [ __ ] say that I
couldn't tell if the guy was nervous he
just sort of talked himself into a
corner and he meant to say he has
nothing to be disappointed about I don't
know what I'm trying to give him the
benefit of the doubt but everyone's just
kind of sitting like
I kind of uh kind of put a [ __ ]
damper on things
I mean minutes have I done it all right
sorry I got the bootleg recorder here
which I have on my stomach too so if you
start here and grumbling I apologize
anyways I was able to watch game was a
game 3 of the NBA Finals when I was in
London at about 2:00 in the morning I
was able to watch and I was able to
watch oh my god the [ __ ] Washington
Capitals when the Stanley Cup
threw Josh Adam Meyers cuz I couldn't
get it on my phone cuz I couldn't
remember my password from [ __ ] you
know my cable company I could have just
gone on to NBC sports and just sat there
and watched it but my daughter and my
wife were sleeping so I was laying a bed
wat in bed wide awake with the lights
out just hitting refresh on my phone
looking at the score and when there was
a few minutes left I text Josh Adam
Meyers and he goes dude he goes full
[ __ ] he was won't tell me he was just
going to NBC Sports and of course it
didn't work out for me cuz I didn't what
password and he will call me up I'll
answer on my computer I'll FaceTime in
assumption so I said alright but here's
the thing I'm gonna be in the dark and I
can't say anything because my my
daughter's sleeping in the same room and
everything so he goes alright call me so
I snuck into the bathroom lights still
out because the only way to turn on the
lights in that [ __ ] hotel rooms I had
to had the bathroom door open which
would have woke my kid up
so I'm sitting in there they're like a
dark in the dark like a creep the only
thing that's lighting me up is off of my
[ __ ] phone it looked like a horror
movie
and Josh was just laughing at me and
he's like can you see can you see and I
just put my pasty white hand up to the
screen giving the thumbs-up and I
actually watched the final three minutes
of the Stanley Cup and I have to tell
you this guy in the Internet put it best
he said he talking about Alexander
Ovechkin he goes I don't can't remember
the last time I was just happy for a
complete stranger that was watching the
Capitals win was everything that
you [ __ ] watch sports for it's
everything that I love about sports and
[Music]
you know anybody that says you know
Russian players don't give a [ __ ] about
the Stanley Cup just all I need to do is
just watch him walking around with that
thing and fakes and how cool is it like
they actually you know it would have
been great if they wanted at home
obviously but like if you're gonna win
it on the road Las Vegas has to be the
place you want to be if you're gonna go
party right and I say it every year the
Stanley Cup is the greatest [ __ ]
championship trophy in all of sports
simply because there's only one and you
grew up as a kid watching all your
heroes hoisting that thing up and when
you in the million to one odds whatever
the [ __ ] it is that you actually win it
when you hoist that thing up you're
holding the same Cup you know Maurice
Rashard Gordie Howe Bobby Orr Wayne
Gretzky Mark Messier Mario Lemieux all
of these greats the same [ __ ] Cup
Yzerman all of those guys you hoist that
[ __ ] thing up said day you know Chara
I thought I had to throw another Peron
in there
it's the coolest [ __ ] thing ever
you know however I would not drink out
of it I can tell you that right now
because I there's been enough guys
who've you know over the years
hockey former hockey players they've
told stories about some of the [ __ ] that
happens to the Stanley Cup he goes yeah
and one of them I vaguely remember
somebody saying I would not drink out of
that thing this stories of strippers
sitting in the top of the [ __ ] thing
and bending it or some [ __ ] like that
I don't know and that each player gets
it for like a week
it's so [ __ ] crazy so crazy and then
there's this guy there's got to be a
[ __ ] movie about that sometime the
poor bastard who has to follow the cup
around all year somebody's must have
done a documentary on it vaguely
remember seeing some [ __ ] like that you
got to follow what you know go up to
[ __ ] a titty bar in Saskatoon
whatever the [ __ ] that come pens up for
the week
but anyways congratulations to the
Washington cab
their first Stanley Cup championship and
what is it 44 years 45 seasons and as I
tweeted one other great thing is NHL has
another great hockey city in Las Vegas
and after all those years of picking
these cities that just you know there
was the initial excitement and then it
just kind of fizzled they kind of hit a
home run in Nashville and Las Vegas and
I got a feeling that Seattle's gonna be
huge just because those fans are maniacs
you know and I'm sure they'll build a
stadium to make them sound even louder
why do I always give them [ __ ] you know
what cuz it's fun because it's fun oh I
heard Edelman got busted for something
peds or something like that and now
they're gonna he's gonna appeal it and
what I'm gonna love about that is now
everybody's gonna be like she that's why
they beat Atlanta and all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] because they're the Patriots that's
how it works you'll just look the other
way when 30% of the Legion of boom
tested positive for [ __ ] steroids
that's alright that's alright that's
Seattle that's okay I at PD sent to my
house and my wife's named it for my wife
she was taking a pop tart out of the
toaster and she hurt her shoulder and
she needed a [ __ ] steroid to get back
in shape again so she could make some
[ __ ] lemon meringue pie anyways if I
had to guess you know we had that
horrific injury and he's doing the Andy
Pettitte thing he's [ __ ] trying to
get back he took some [ __ ] roids and
he got caught it took something and got
caught is what I'm thinking but I do
know at any time anybody seems to appeal
these things I don't think that they
ever goes back the other way but I'm
glad that I'm not in the u.s. to listen
to ESPN and all these [ __ ] guys now
saying oh yeah yeah they should take
away all their titles because they got
caught they had a player get caught
doing what a player got caught on every
other [ __ ] team is done
so anyways enough enough with the sports
[ __ ] I am in patty I'm in Patty and I am
with my French I didn't brush up as nuf
as I wanted to and it's making me
discouraged but I'm hanging in there
I got my I got my [ __ ] uh what do you
call it
rosetta stone and that [ __ ] I'll do when
you when you go to the [ __ ] French
Open all right and you have your ticket
you go in and you got to have the
[ __ ] things scanned and then FP gets
scanned you get this little [ __ ] it's
like a ticket the size of them they put
in your [ __ ] wiper when you're when
you pay for parking all right and then
everywhere you go you have to take that
thing out and they have to scan it to
know where the [ __ ] you are at all times
you know I went into the goddamn gift
shop bought a little [ __ ] 20:18
Roland Garros mug and he goes I need you
know let me scan your ticket and that's
just like I wish just said no you're not
scanning my [ __ ] ticket I'm paying
for that so now what is that ad does
that add to my whole [ __ ] information
online he's into drums he does this he
drinks too much whiskey and he can't lay
off of a mug when he's in some touristy
[ __ ] place now I'm gonna get all
these [ __ ] ads now I'm gonna get all
these ads and then the side when I go to
[ __ ] porno sites and [ __ ] about mugs
funny if they had why don't they have a
gift shop on online porn porn why though
they are good actually they probably do
so anyways every [ __ ] place you went
you had to keep taking it out keep
taking out putting away whatever so now
finally I'm going you know I bought like
a [ __ ] stillwater in a crepe for my
wife and I had to get the things scanned
you know what I'm in another country so
I'm at my best behavior normally I would
be like why the [ __ ] do I have to scan
this but the others why I didn't say it
says I don't know how to say why the
[ __ ] do do I have to get this thing
scanned you know in French on phone say
right so now I go to walk in it's five
or three franch time and the match
starts at three o'clock right so we go
to go in and guess what I can't find cuz
I've had to take it out of my pocket 58
[ __ ] times I can't find the ticket I
need to get
to the goddamn match but I had that
other thing in the ladies like I'm sorry
sir you couldn't have to get into the
bay but Sapodilla I was [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
just like are you serious and then she
got mad at me she's like yes yes I had
to go all the way the [ __ ] back wade
through all of these goddamn people then
go to customer service oh my god
the [ __ ] Tourette's that was going
off me as I walked all the way back past
all of these [ __ ] people and I got to
give it up to the French people you know
you guys you know you don't smell as bad
as everybody says but I will say this
when you do holy [ __ ] dude when we
walked out of the stadium there was this
guide like [ __ ] he was probably good
six feet in front of me and I said Jesus
Christ we actually made he went left
down the stairs after one flight I went
right and I tried to get away from the
guy I said and I had my shirt up over my
nose so bad this guy spelled I said to
me I could she's Christ this guy smells
like he [ __ ] played how do you smell
that bad sitting watching people working
out maybe because he was walking down
the stairs fast he was creating a breeze
and it was passing through his [ __ ]
French armpits but holy Sh it did that
guy stink
not as bad as a homeless guy but like he
smelled like he you know freshly
homeless good three four days you know
maybe a tornado hit his [ __ ] house
and FEMA hadn't come over to help him
get that's what this [ __ ] guy's
smelled like sitting you know and tennis
is a really snobby [ __ ] rich person's
sport especially down below you know up
top it's a bunch of animals that's what
we were sitting and if you ever go we
got front row in the upper deck get the
second row
upper deck because front row they had
this glass thing but you know that
you'll partition that you look through
but on top of it they have this solid
thing that all holds it together and I
was like in America this would have been
clear plastic so I had to look over and
duck under it the whole [ __ ] match
which was still fine
so anyways but down low is where all the
[ __ ] you know
the coaches are the super [ __ ] rich
people and they go there and like [ __ ]
outfits and their big dumb hats and all
that [ __ ] but all the animals were up
top you know doing the wave and [ __ ]
when Nadal had some problem going on
with his servant hand or his arm I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened and but
anyways I was it was it was an amazing
[ __ ] time so I had to go all the way
back and I got the ticket then I came
walking up and I you know after all that
flipping out but all of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] I still made it in time to see
the match as always
99% of time I flip out later on there's
a solution whatever I thought was going
to happen because he didn't convenience
never [ __ ] happens and I thought I
was gonna leave all of that behind in my
40s but evidently it's gonna continue I
started strong the day has turned 50
it [ __ ] it just continued on so I'm
gonna rent a [ __ ] bicycle today and
I'm gonna ride around Paris where my my
daughter goes to sleep and we just been
having the the best time here as always
gonna take a well-deserved [ __ ]
little vacation here and the hardest
thing for me on vacation is not to just
plain a bunch of [ __ ] every day you know
and then it just becomes a thrash it's
funny like we we drove by was it that no
true Dom or some [ __ ] like that and the
guy driving us was going to go you know
it's beautiful you got to go in there a
blah blah and I sweat it I'm just not
into that [ __ ] those old churches and
stuff you walk in and I just look around
it's just like yeah you guys you guys
really decorated the [ __ ] out of this
place didn't you you know negative space
in here it's all just filled up with the
most gaudy you know you know I think you
know like the migos dress looks like the
Church version of that where you just
can't have enough [ __ ] precious
stones and I like how those you know the
new
where you get a lamborghini then you do
the [ __ ] shiny wrap that you put
around it it's like it wasn't enough
that it was a [ __ ] Lamborghini
there's old churches it's like it's not
enough that you have 90-foot [ __ ]
ceilings all right then you gotta have a
bunch of sad brokenhearted people
painted up there in like real gold and
all of this crazy hocus-pocus [ __ ] up
there like I I don't have any desire to
do that but uh you know there's no line
I'll poke my head in and be like wow wow
this old church looks exactly like every
other old church it's creepy I feel like
I'm gonna catch tuberculosis cuz it's
cold and damp in here and the vibe in
here is not the vibe where good things
happen so I'm gonna leave now yeah so
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] ride my bike
around today like the big [ __ ]
nancy-boy that I am maybe burn a few
calories I brought my little exercise
bands over here because I'm old my
shoulder feels [ __ ] great but I got a
problem with my [ __ ] left foot you
know it's just always something tell me
something I'm an old old bad people I'm
50 how the [ __ ] did that happen you know
it's actually gotta be kind of be honest
it's kind of a cool age to turn in a lot
of ways you know God knows I had a bunch
of friends that didn't make it this far
so how the [ __ ] can I sit here in [ __ ]
and I like a nice round number you know
30 sucked 40 was like a low fifties been
cool but I'll tell you 60 is gonna crush
me you know what's great about 50 you
can lie to yourself through your 40s I'm
a young 40 something above 50 it's like
not dude you're [ __ ] old so I am old
and I'm going to embrace it maybe I'll
start dressing a little more dapper on
stage get myself a little pocket square
hangin out of my button-down all right
let's three a little bit of advertising
here oh look who's here
these guys have been with me since my
40s dollars shave
dude if you ever [ __ ] shower or brush
your teeth or try to make your hair look
presentable well I do most of those too
what a three input here's some good news
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of self a
lot of stuff to help you out
jolly shape club yes that's Dollar Shave
Club delivers everything you need to
look feel and smell your best you name
it they got it Shampoo got it
conditioner check body wash I said we
got everything toothpaste hair gel even
a wipe that will leave you a touch
feeling tingly clean it's sort of the
poor man's bidet you'll be a big fan of
their amber and lavender calming body
cleanser after you try it the first time
does that really work I wish I had some
of that yesterday when I couldn't find
my ticket to the tennis match they
should just have that in a Miss for
someone angry bald [ __ ] like Meg
shows up and they just hit me with a
[ __ ] amber and lavender we got an
Amber situation over here Amber Alert
right
lavender Louie good luck finding a
product that's that great at this store
all of Dollar Shave club's products are
made with top-shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget you feel the
difference plus shipping is included in
your membership and is a great way to
try a bunch of Dollar Shave Club
products for just 5 bucks you can get
their daily essentials essential starter
set it comes with body cleanser one
white jar
they're amazing butt wipes their
world-famous shave butter and their best
razor the six blade executive and add in
shampoo moment executive sorry keep the
blades coming for few more bucks a month
and add in shampoo toothpaste or
anything else you need speaking of you
next month for a limited time only use
the code burr at checkout to get five
dollars off your second month of the
club that's code Barbie you are our
dollarshaveclub.com to save $5 on your
second month join the club today all
right couple more movement watches and
VMT spring is right around the corner
I think
this spring I think summer is right
around the corner and movement is
dropping all new sunglasses or what is
that loonette's tonight say then
loonette's Soleil
to get your get you ready for the warmer
weather talk about individual styles and
events you have coming up that you want
to look good in shades for oh the next
sporting event that I'm going to is in
24 hours LeMans and when I inevitably
lose my ticket I would like to have some
lavender miss a nice movement watch a
pair of aviators and a one white cherry
and then maybe I'll be able to keep my
cool over there we just go what let's
talk about individual NZ shades of allah
we just go to our go to shades for who's
we why are they always doing this if you
want this [ __ ] that they're selling just
you know for their go to shades that the
guys at movement don't just make great
watches hello Nene thank you for an
awesome birthday like I just picked the
one thing like I was in was that Run DMC
know how they used to do it sure I'd
finish your sentence yeah right you want
to come up with a rap right now I wanna
you supposed to say baguette baguette
okay that's it that's the end of the rap
you didn't fill my flow there I wanna
that's me rapping you think you know
jay-z scared right now we just go to I
just go to our shades for it all the
guys in movement hey Nia the guys that
move with a dose they just don't make
great watches if you thought that was
the only good thing they did they also
make awesome sunglasses or lunettes
hungry so sewing bowl they so they have
and just reached a ton of new styles our
friends at movement yeah to watch guys
they kind of felt the same way so they
thought screw it who they were feeling
sassy that day I'm sure they didn't say
[ __ ] how about we make quality trendy
sunglasses at a fair price
why is screw it in quotes I think that's
because they said [ __ ] it these things
aren't plastic they acetate acetate as
oh they're acetate yeah I thought it was
mine you can get them polarized and they
start at just $70 and acetate acetate
acetate these are seriously that's when
you go to look it up to see how you say
these are seriously my go-to shades talk
about movements various can these
[ __ ] [ __ ] right to copy talk
about varied selections and styles well
there's aviators there's the one Tom
Cruise wore that in was it losing it or
risky business why are you blaming them
for the bad that you can't read there's
nothing wrong with a copy what are you
talking I know
then there's talk about movements
various selections in style
oh they keep doing that I know I can't
read talk about how awesome we are talk
about MVM tees various save selection
and styles finding the perfect pair you
know watery with free shipping and free
returns I like to I like your ring yeah
I like that ring and make it I like that
read because then I don't have to do it
talk about movements berries selections
in style
sleek matte black - really fun retro
round shades and how finding the perfect
pair is risk-free with free shipping and
free returns he can't do it yeah that
was good that was gonna pay these are
high-quality premium as the tape acetate
acetate frames no cheap plastic here you
got to see these they have lots of
styles to choose from classic trendy
round aviator
merit polarize for him and her
see they just talked about it you talk
about it it's your stuff you talk about
and tell me what to talk about you're
sure to find the perfect fare get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to movement comm / /
that's
MVM t.com / / join the movement Nia did
you have fun at the tennis match
yesterday I know I know it's really hot
how bad did that guy smell when we left
hey they stink oh all right you call me
stink Oh
let me just read so much fun oh how do
you say that was one smelly [ __ ]
number we shot down the other stairs
only to meet him again down the bottom
stamps.com the US Postal Service is an
important tool for any business
stamps.com is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office
stamps.com never closes print postage
for letters or packages at your own
convenience 24/7 print postage for any
mail class right from your own computer
the exact amount of postage every time
never under pay or over pay again I just
mailed all of my posters to Dublin and
to London using stamps calm it was very
easy however I mailed too many to Dublin
it was an 8000 seater I was like what
should I send there like five hundred
stupid the magic number is two hundred
there's two hundred people you'll sell
two hundred if there's two hundred
thousand you'll sell two hundred I don't
I can't understand it so by the way
people who like the poster that I have
it's only available at my shows because
I tried to sell stuff online and then I
have to [ __ ] sit there and deal with
like I'm not from sois Hulu I'm from
Swahili I didn't get my [ __ ] poster
and you know half the time people give
you the wrong goddamn address and say
what am I am isn't yeah that's a
language does that way I'm only pointing
them no I wish you just stop that's a
language that was great you just shut me
down I'm just worried about because my
name is Swahili so okay evidently this
whole podcast is about you now
is it can you make a Swahili dish it's
not as well Healy dish that's the
language well I can make a French dish
okay that's a language French it's also
interesting I can mail any laughing yes
it's also a kiss so what type of fry
what do you got anything else French
tickler
oh it's also a tickler it's also a cuff
on your shirt you know what this is good
cuz I just finished watching Kanye West
on family feud so I feel like I'm
answering family feud right now he was
on camera promoting his new album no
it's saying that he loves Donald Trump I
know that was controversial what do you
got a new album or something
I think babies should be illegal why
here's my new album
oh that sounds pretty catchy I use
stamps comb already did all this and
right now you you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with this special
offer that includes a full week trial
plus postage and a digital scale go to
stamps com click on the microphone top
of the homepage and type in / that
stamps com enter BRR alright Nene it's
you know what I love being here in Paris
Niall whenever I see your beauty in
Paris I always think when the moon hits
your eye like a big pizza pie that's
Italian
that is why would I be singing that here
what's a good French song frere Jenna
you have a classically beautiful place
I've always told you you it's your
cheekbones that's where the light hits
when you go to look to the left it's the
right and in the right lit restaurant
I'm just like there it is we had a great
that's how I ended the freedom of my
single life but we had an awesome time
lesson that was so fun we ended up
meeting up with friends we ran into a
friend at the royal end down
at all that was so [ __ ] random so
random there's about a hundred gift
shops at the Roland Garros we just
happened to run into but we went into
the bad one the one that everybody goes
into this night it's over it was yeah
you want to go to the boutique boutique
once yeah there's an Adidas store I saw
that on the way up but I was trying to
beat the crowd all how funny was that
were like we got to get away from the
crowd so we can get a [ __ ] uber and
and I went right when everybody else
went left just to you know get a few
blocks over to gives somebody a chance
and all the streets are blocked off and
we ended up going from Roland Garros and
just walked past I thought was a parking
garage
it was another Stadium when I looked at
soccer magic oh yeah that's like the
next door was another soccer stadium
like wow this is like Stadium row over
here but of course we call the uber and
the guy couldn't come down the street
and it just was whatever it was yes we
did I had a lovely dinner and then we
ended up meeting up with the friends
that we ran into at Roland Garros plus
another friend of yours plus some
friends of mine yeah we all met up in a
yeah it was four couples and we just
ended up having this table at the cafe
late night we shut it down and you guys
sang me happy birthday yeah champagne so
much fun by the way do you know it's one
of the only times anybody's ever sung
happy birthday to me and I haven't been
embarrassed really it's happened three
times in my life alright there it Boyle
Albert Hall so it was twice the same
birthday and then last year when I was
on stage in Montreal they all sang happy
but I was one of the coolest things that
ever happened to me the crowd all sang
it and the fact that they sang it to a
Bruin fan that we could set aside our
differences just one night to celebrate
one bald heck yeah in that moment you
know which gives me hope that when
Donald Trump goes to talk to old fatty
[ __ ] fat face over there he can you
imagine like you being that fat when all
your people are starving now granted I
know it's people are starving because of
our friggin
Bargo they trying to make it seem like
he's like a dictator so of course he's
gonna be like all fat and he lobster and
duck and drinking the best wine every
night we're talking about kim jong right
keep going you gotta have the right name
that's they're all kim jong hoon Kim
Jong and his dad was Kim Jong Il I was
gonna say that June his wife calling for
dinner you oh yeah
hey Kim Jong hey Alisa I'm trying to
tell you something that picture that I
posted of you on my Instagram for your
birthday it got over 5,000 likes that's
great you're really into that aren't you
yeah I'd like some retweets yes I do I
am I'm into all of that I'm an
influencer so if you want to tell the
story why why you want to tell the story
why you mock that whole influencer thing
what is my story
you don't remember no when we first
heard the term influencer uh-huh you
were gonna do something and then you
couldn't because they wanted influencers
oh yeah I was asked to be a part of
don't name any names I won't I was asked
to be a part of a storyteller show and
what was the thing yes and the theme was
like cultural diversity and families and
stuff so I was like oh sure right up do
le there yeah yeah we have an
interracial relationship we have a
biracial child it's kind of yeah I can
come up with something for that and then
the person who asked me said that they
had to disinvite me because they wanted
more influencers so the network wanted
more network wanted more influencers and
you know so they got they replaced me
with someone who had apparently more
quote-unquote influence and that just
means more friends and thing or whatever
the [ __ ] it is people on social media
Lee and I didn't even really dig into
this person was but apparently they were
terrible and the whole show was like
kind of awkward and not that great so
it's fine but I was so offended that I
wasn't seen as an influence or when I
have like you know at healthy following
on
Twitter and Instagram that I just
decided that I was gonna be in it I'm
one of the greatest influences ever I am
an influencer I like that that's the
bottom line like I feel like at this
point I don't even need to keep telling
people anymore it's just who you are yes
it's just coming out of your pores
yeah like naturally people want to be
like me so you know it's weird for some
reason I don't know just looking at some
reason I want braids right now well
that's the thing like if I have it you
want it and that's what an influencer
does that's yeah and what is is you
didn't even tell me to get it you just
had it and I was like I want that yeah
could you see how good it looks on me
and so you're like wow can I look like
that there's only way to find out it's
just to get it and then you're like oh I
don't but I tried and it's like that's
really what it's about that's that's
what an influencer does yeah exactly you
just exist in this space like your own
zeitgeist like you were your own
movement you are your own moment is this
something could you teach this to
somebody else oh god no no no you either
have it or you don't
so if you want to become an influencer
I'm not really quite sure what to tell
you because it's like you already have
some sort of calling is it is it a gift
how would you describe like yeah it's
just it's it's a state of being you know
what I mean it's like you're just always
influencing all the time so I can't
teach it I can't explain it
does that get taxing or tiring it'll you
know it really doesn't you know because
it's like breathing there you go people
and some inside tips are not to be a
[ __ ] influencer yep I can't believe
that people walked away from you know
you just influenced me to try to read up
more on influencers alright hey people
gummy uh send me some Paris tips here
okay by the way did you read that thing
about the wine country the email that I
forward you one of our listeners wrote
in maybe evidently I'm not an influencer
alright just an email from your husband
that says wine country
you know you'd think that one wouldn't
you'd at least open I know you don't
open the ones that I send you that they
have the subject are you mad at me all
right
Paris chips they still write into the
box
right no [ __ ] trash over there hey
thank you for the best birthday that was
the best birthday I've ever had it was
it was I've had two back-to-back last
year was the was the selfish one where I
wasn't I was in Montreal and I went to
an f1 race who I don't you know who won
that did Lewis Hamilton win it again I
gotta look that up a little behind you
but this year was the best all right you
know T's about the song happy birthday
it's really long and it almost sounds
like people are making fun of you happy
birthdays as a you're a douchebag yes
you are and then at the end it's always
speech speech so I actually I thought
what I said at Royal Albert Hall was
really nice and I was like I did it I
got through it knocked it out thanked
everybody and I'm done and then as I'm
walking away people would go speech
speech just [ __ ] game one I still
didn't get angry leave me alone God all
right Paris tips hey Bill I am a fan
from Perry I heard you were visiting our
lovely City soon this is my franch
accent make sure you stop by lecompt wha
in Sasha I'm at Metro Odeon as we get up
for a nice meal then take your lovely
lady to the cafe than are all in Rue
Dauphine for a late drink and some jazzy
entertainment that sounds good
they have a nice garden where you can
smoke a cigar and sip on some scotch
/ wine also don't learn French it's
useless better to learn Chinese instead
enjoy your stay and go [ __ ] yourself
let's go do that
alright thank you thank you for that -
now I want to try what's that guy in
no he's more of an informer and as the
gesture
can we please label everybody that
[ __ ] he's a suggester that'd be funny
if that was in his truck no I am NOT I'm
not a suggester I was me I'm a presenter
I was presenting information that you
can do you know it was a suggestion it's
really what it was it's not bad to
suggest things but your suggestion even
in this age of me - hey I suggest you
come over in your honor it was just a
suggestion
that's my Z's my sausage crazy lawsuit
crazy law sue all right hey there Billy
birthday cake wondering if your friends
in the comic community passed this on to
you oh please don't anticipate performer
getting suit take a shower do you say
take a shower and something douche yeah
all right wondering if your friends in
the comic community of wha meaning of
why influence err wondering if your
friends in the comic community passed
this on to you back story this guy oh my
god you touched my hair and then you hit
E this guy Maddox like the TV show who
started a page in the 90s called the
best page in the universe he became
famous for calling out Christopher
Reeves for not caring about paraplegics
till he became one himself well I mean
Jesus Christ out of all the things to
call people out on basically lambasted
him for being a selfish piece of [ __ ]
Jesus Christ I don't understand he never
sold me on the aggressive manner of
hating Reeves
the only way he keek he does this
without looking like an [ __ ] as if
he was also in a wheelchair you know and
lived at the top of a flight of stairs
or some [ __ ] and no one ever made
ramp form then I could see him being mad
at Christopher ease but even then it
would still be misdirected it still
should be aimed at people like myself
that then go over there and help build
him a [ __ ] ramp anyways but I
appreciated a different point of view on
topics no one questioned and so I that's
okay but I appreciate a different point
of view on topics no one questioned and
so I had some respect for this he also
had a post called something like I can
draw better than your kids and then
posted pictures kids made and trash them
alright I like this guy now because this
guy's just being a [ __ ]
he's just for this good maybe he's the
original troller I like it because that
was like 15 years ago I hadn't heard of
him since college until I read about
this lawsuit apparently this same guy
who made a career trolling the people on
a personal level across the internet
became offended by a comic who decided
to troll him oh no no he had no sense of
humor about himself or is this more
trolling is this guy the Andy Kaufman of
the Internet he sued the comic for
twenty million dollars which is
basically way to bankrupt the comic for
whatever little he had the judge
essentially threw out the case on the
advent of your 50th birthday I just want
to thank you for not turning into a huge
hypocrite like Maddox I'll dude I'm one
of those hypocritical people you ever
gonna meet doing yoga meditating and
then flipping out because I cuz I lost
my ticket saying this whole sisters
[ __ ] stupid really build the system
that makes sure that when you get to
your seat some others [ __ ] [ __ ]
not sitting in it you [ __ ] up
take your medicine and I didn't act like
a big [ __ ] baby even if he thought he
was being wrong he should have taken it
like a man realized that he had to come
in after years doing the same thing to
others you don't feel like this is the
final act of his performance and now
he's gotten you up in arms
you're a few years older than me and
I've definitely taken a page on your
book in terms of allowing myself to stay
true to who I am but also allowing
myself to grow into a more well-rounded
person I'm a no an egg fan
what a from back in the day and it's my
favorite content ever but when I see
comments online that sound like they
came from the crowd at the virus store I
just feel bad for these miserable [ __ ]
thanks for everything and happy birthday
all right that went a little left there
but I know what you mean about the that
happens with everything by the way not
just fans of the Opie and Anthony show
this I mean go on YouTube there's always
gonna be the initial thing that you like
and then you look at the comments and I
forget what comic did that bit but it
was just like you know you scroll down
like three or four comments before it
spins into like somebody dropping the
n-word or some you know thanks a lot
Obama likes em I'll that'll be watching
like slap whites like that's the [ __ ]
that I watch which I do not understand
those for the life of me first of all
the fact that if they hit your ear what
that's gonna do to your hearing you know
do you know that was a thing that like I
gotta look this up mom's used to do that
that was like a disciplinarian thing
back in the day you blocks you mother's
box boxing their children's it's just
too specific I don't think I'll get
anything ears they were just you know it
was like Killick on how he used to do
that that scream wah oh man just hit
boxing the ears okay
boxing here's the other Victorians
Anthony Joshua says there's nothing
wrong with parents giving them which one
should I click on here world champion
boxer Anthony said there's nothing wrong
with parents giving their children a
clip around the Year boxing child's ears
can cause deafness yes it can
let's look this one up here unable to
open this because of legal reasons the
[ __ ] does that mean
alright boxing gears let's see if this
one will open up come on come on come on
there we go alright a phrase that can
used me while reading Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland was the rabbit's
explanation of why the Queen ordered the
Duchess to be executed in Chapter eight
what if I've never seen Alice in
Wonderland there's a queen and a Duchess
and all this [ __ ] people getting
executed I you know something you know
why I think there's so much death in old
fairy tales the original ones because so
many people just [ __ ] die back then
anyway so it really was a part of life
the rabbit eggs I'm een it's still a
part of life but it's it's way down the
[ __ ] road but everybody had like a
brother who died of like the [ __ ]
appendix ruptured appendix or some [ __ ]
got some sort of flu all right the
rabbit explains to Alice she boxed the
Queen's ears the actions of boxing ears
is something I had never heard of so I
decided to look into the meaning of the
term I found that boxing of ears is a
hard simultaneous slap of both ears yeah
the violent act was a popular form of
child punishment during the Victorian
era oh my god in an 1878 issue of the
London reader of literature science art
and general information the punishment
of boxing ears is debated the article
warms is 1878 people like do but the
[ __ ] are we doing here for not only is
deafness caused by boxes which ruptures
as they continually do the drum of the
ear but the inflammation of the internal
cavity which is so frequent a result may
be followed by disease of the bone
giving rise to absent - abscess of the
brain and having a fatal termination I
like how they took picked a euphemism
there rather than saying your kid's
gonna [ __ ] die the article explains
that schoolboys are suffering from the
chastisement by school masters and fears
as noted above that the effects of the
slaps may be long-term I swear to
[ __ ] god if my if I have had a
teacher that boxed my ears oh my god I
mean how angry were children back then
oh my god I really have to walk away
from this article
ah man I wish there was you know some
[ __ ] kid back then just [ __ ]
snapped it was just big enough you know
you just beat the [ __ ] out of his
teacher and boxed his ears like nine
times made him a deaf [ __ ] bastard
yeah so whenever I watch those slap
fights it's just like you're gonna make
somebody deaf do they put something in
their ear forget about just taking a
concussion for no goddamn reason I mean
we'll all those slap fight competitions
like what is the [ __ ] prize money
anyways continuing on bear and Monsanto
whoa Jesus didn't uh I guess see what
time I've done here 53 minutes right
didn't Monsanto changes her name like
Jefferson Airplane or some [ __ ]
bear in Monsanto hey there you
over-the-counter [ __ ]
so Baron Monsanto are merging and
reminded me of the time you mentioned an
article where Bayer admitted to knowing
and allowing the distribution of some
aids infected [ __ ] found the article
full this sounds official first of all
came from me and then you described the
article the subject of the article has
AIDS infected [ __ ] well let's check out
the link it is from CBS news.com
so all right bear admits it paid
millions in HIV infection cases just not
in English oh my god dude I swear to God
at what point how much money do you have
to pay politicians where they feel like
they have enough money and they don't
need the corporate dollar and that they
can actually start to dismantle or
restructure these corporations these
corporations are gonna kill us not Isis
not [ __ ] the Russians
none of this [ __ ] [ __ ] all right when
I say kill us I mean no human beings
left are going to be the result about
because of corporations all right and
what how they view people how they view
the in
and how they view money in their whole
idea of what is his worth I mean I just
never heard a corporation ever being
like you know what the the the cost to
innocent people or the environment is
too high for us to do that maybe they do
and be refreshing if you have an article
like that that wasn't actually written
by someone from that corporation that's
lying
alright so to read the english-speaking
media
you'd never know that bear just paid
tens of millions of dollars to end a
three decade long scandal in which the
company sold HIV contaminated blood
products to hemophiliacs thousands of
whom later died of AIDS they just killed
thousands of [ __ ] people or admitted
to it but that doesn't mean they
actually said that they did it you know
that [ __ ] legal thing ironically
Bears knew hemophilia hemophilia iPhone
app got some coverage ads did bears
hemophilia research grant I covered
their tracks to the University of
Florida go Gators but you have to pick
through the French and Italian news
media to find out that bear is finally
writing checks to people who got AIDS
I've got HIV that turned into AIDS in
the 1980s the cutter biological unit of
Bayer ignored federal law to recruit
prisoners intravenous drug users and
high-risk gay men as donors all they
ignored that of the blood cutter then
used to make factor 8 and 9 the clotting
product that hemophiliacs need to order
need in order to not bleed to death oh
so they pulled a bela check whether they
were like alright you guys are all
filming lead the team on the sidelines
you can no longer do that and they just
ignored it
alright the German group bear in three
other labs will pay tens of millions of
euros to hemophiliacs who accused them
of having sold in the 1980s blood
products contaminated with HIV a source
close to deal told so did it was it that
they knew that it
HIV in it or did they just went to
high-risk people to get blood the figure
of tens of millions of euros in
compensation is not totally wrong
she had a bear in the US company Baxter
are the two main parties to the
agreement she said a company
spokesperson said hello the company
accepts no responsibility in this case
and continues to insist and it always
acted responsibly and ethically that's
how they get out of it it's like all
right we'll admit that we did that [ __ ]
if you say it wasn't our fault and that
we always behaved aboveboard you know
what that's like that's like when they
send somebody to jail an innocent person
to jail and then they're like alright
we're gonna let you out but the only way
we can let you out as if you sign this
paper saying you won't sue us because we
[ __ ] up
anyways found the article I just read
some of it they're still in business
though they're still in business can't
bring down bear that's our medicine but
maybe our food supply nope then you got
I don't know what this guy's talking
about now then you got Monsanto we can't
be sued because Obama's signed that law
saying that you can't sue Monsanto now
they're a super team corporations are
like NBA teams huh you got room in the
chopper for me bill this guy was all
over the place
all right and why did Obama sue that
sign that so that why did he sign that
bill everybody is it because he's a
liberal [ __ ] snowflake or whatever
people get in wears a blue tie or is it
because he's grossly underpaid for his
[ __ ] job and it's and I bet those
guys funded his [ __ ] campaign so then
he had to do them a solid it's all the
same [ __ ] they all make five hundred
grand a year and then come out of office
worth hundreds of millions of whatever
[ __ ] 7080 million bucks
how does that happen everybody although
recently I saw Bill Clinton when that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] brought up the me2
thing you know with Monica Lewinsky I
love all they tried to make that a
me-too thing
you know what I mean it's like she was
in her twenties she was a college
graduate she never learned that she
should that's what I was saying on stage
she never learned that you shouldn't
blow a married guy in his house with his
wife and kid down the [ __ ] hall she
didn't know that now she's coming back
you know everything fluids buddies power
and it was your Whoopie boo people we
get the [ __ ] out of here you were a
driven young adult who somehow in your
twenties got a job in the [ __ ] White
House okay you weren't some dopey
founded a bus station hi Nia how about
that Monica Lewinsky thing well now that
she's trying to like turn it around that
he used his power and influence it's
like you were a college graduate working
in the White House right I know and he
got punished poor but in that thing he
said claim was like I left the White
House I was sixteen million dollars in
debt you don't I mean he that's true I
think he's the only [ __ ] president
ever did that oh geez she's she's
getting ready for nap time
all right big band drumming dear bill
I'm 17 years old and I play drums every
day that's awesome it's my life and I'm
in every band jazz concert in Marchant
good band and I play percussion for the
chorus and for the school plays Kenny
ere enough is my hero well I was gonna
say that sounds like his autobiography
how we started out thank you for that
dream interview I have it on a playlist
with music that's how much I listen to
it let's go I'm glad you liked it you
know yeah not for nothing people say I
actually do a good interview yeah I'm
Kenny Aronoff the Danica Patrick to my
lovely wife you know I set you guys up
no not you guys you know I love it over
the plate I learned that by going on
Conan
that's what he does I mean Andrea they
they just they just lob it over to you
all right Andy Richter my day was
telling me about my dad was telling me
about the sky movement in the 90s I just
watched swingers and discovered this
band
Squirrel Nut Zippers oh my god takes you
back to college tasty it's really takes
me back to my early 30s that was in my
late twenties it's really different than
anything I've heard I discovered that I
don't like all ska but I like these guys
because it's more big-band than Scott
I really think you enjoy the drumming
it's really a cool mix between big band
drumming punk and almost some Primus
type drumming stuff because of the Tom
work did you get ever get into any of
that
I remember that Big Bad Voodoo Daddy and
that type of stuff I liked it a little
bit but I was a little too old at that
point that was actually kids music to me
this is what our lovely daughter does
before afternoon nap she screams bloody
murder and then falls asleep
Nolan talks to herself when she comes
down and then falls asleep anyways I
doubt this will get read because it's
too nerdy but maybe just maybe thanks
for the laughs Oh Billy rim shot no I
like all that stuff I mean I like fun
Robert Plant with Jesus I like to Robin
planted that the honey dripper sing with
Paul Shaffer I've always liked big bands
and that type of stuff and I really like
the way all of that music is the
Squirrel Nut Zippers and all that I just
like the way it was produced it sounded
really live and and also you know when
you get that many people in a band and
they can all play it's it's always
sounds great so Big Bad Voodoo today was
also in swinger song okay I did not know
that oh yeah they were rough they were
great they are great I should say right
what do they figure out a play all right
being rude to waitstaff all right even
hey there Billy bath salts you're really
talking about Nia being slightly rude to
waitstaff and it made me hear the word
got cut off something a podcast I heard
years back about raising kids
essentially a group of economists gave
their opinions on what you can and can't
change in children supported with
studies and evidence one person suggests
with evidence that there are only a
small number of habits that kids pick up
from their parents those habits are
drinking alcohol smoking and how we
treat others waitstaff family etc well
those are kind of big things as a former
bartender who's dealt with incredibly
rude patrons I would love to hear you
and Nia debate if she is actually being
rude or not if she feels she's not being
rude would she'd be okay if she saw her
daughter treating a family member the
way she treats waitstaff absolutely she
would love me and can't wait to hear her
thoughts here's a link to a podcast as a
new debt I think you'll dig it have a
great summer and I hope you get
sunburned you some Aman [ __ ]
Nia do you feel as an influencer why
can't you just influence them to make
better a better service I am NOT rude I
just if something goes wrong I just let
them know and I'm direct about it I'm
not like I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
asked for such-and-such I don't do that
cuz what am i apologizing for I'm like
no I ordered this can you change it
thank you that's it
what do I had with like you want me to
[ __ ] blow the waiter because he did
something wrong like you know allowing
me no I'm just saying you throw a little
sugar on it
in the end like that you did one time it
was cold and you said can you have them
go back and he toughness you oh my god
I'm so sorry yeah yeah cuz it's like
yeah as they want to take the way and I
was just like you remember everybody was
at the table like god damn near no
everybody who was everybody at the table
was like god Danny
Emily now that didn't happen nope
I don't either I don't remember it so
maybe it didn't happen but like I don't
remember it
maybe if it happened that was hilarious
what the [ __ ] ourselves that didn't
happen I don't remember that
yeah maybe it did happen I don't recall
ever being behaving in such a manner
that it would be like so thank you so
great that you're adorable even when you
lie yeah I go the other way I'm too nice
and we'll eat [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
they send me you know you know when they
send me the wrong thing I still eat it
because I don't want because I don't
want to throw it out in the kitchen
later on no yeah you're telling me if
somebody brought a plate of food out
into public and they said that's not
what I wanted and brought it back you'd
be like oh look he needed somebody might
well how do you know they haven't put
that [ __ ] mouth on it was like oh
this isn't ravioli this is french toast
I thought it looked weird and then you
go over there and you get the old
breakfast herpes all right that's the
podcast I gotta find out why my lovely
little boo bears crying downstairs
well she spawns all she in the bedroom
okay
all right well I gotta get off my day
here avoir le monde je m'appelle
Guillaume